-Today, usually, you know,
at the end of the week
that's when I catch up
with some personal stuff
I check my inbox, return some
e-mails and of course I send out
my thank you notes,
and I was running --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was running
a bit behind today,
so I thought, if you guys
wouldn't mind,
I'd just like to write out my
weekly thank you notes
right now, during the show,
is that okay with you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
What's that?
-During the show?
-What's that?
-You don't have any time other?
-This is the only time I got.
The audience says it's cool.
And so you're the only one
-Seems like your time management
is very poor.
-Well, you know I was --
-Every week you just seem to not
be able --
-Well, every week, I try to
write these out
but things happen and I,
you know.
-Right.
-Today I was just so busy.
-What were you doing?
-I got a lower back tattoo.
[ Laughter ]
I just wish the Budweiser frog
hung in there longer.
-oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-James, can I get some
thank you note writing music
please?
Oh, wow.
♪♪
-Yeah, there you go.
[ Clears throat ]
-Wow.
-Put you in the mood for laughs.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, "Matrix:
Resurrections'" trailer,
for reminding me how weird
things get if you take
DayQuil and NyQuil
at the same time.
It's a, it's a mind --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Gotta even yourself out.
-Thank you,
start of the NFL season,
for giving Americans a new
reason to be mad at people
from others states.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Imitates yelling ]
Thank you, September,
for being the one month
fantasy football is fun before
all of your friends start to
make it way too serious.
[ Laughter ]
We said no trades!
We said no trades
after 10:00 p.m.
It's fantasy football, okay?
Thank you,
first day of school photos,
for giving every kid a chance to
take their very own mug shot.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I feel it's faster,
I thought it would be faster
to just lick it and just not
stick it in the envelope.
-Right.
-But still mail it.
-Yeah, you're still gonna mail
it, to I don't know who,
but you're gonna mail it.
-Yeah.
Ted, they get them.
School photos still gets
the thank you note.
-Yeah.
School photo, yeah.
Thank you, everything bagels,
for looking like
a glazed donut hooked up
with a bird feeder.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's my favorite bagel.
-Everything bagel?
-An everything bagel.
I do everything bagel --
-Right.
-Raw.
-Not toasted.
-Not toasted, no.
-Who would toast my bagel.
-Toast my bagel?
No toasting, raw, sushi-fied.
-Right.
-Raw, sushi bagel, with veggie
cream cheese.
-Veggie cream cheese?
That's good.
-That's where you get healthy.
-Yeah.
-You ever have a flagel?
-What's a flagel?
-Apparently,
was talking to Ed Platt,
he's our camera operator,
he says the flagel,
which I've had before,
it's a flattened bagel.
-Oh, I always called that
a bialy.
-You're right, I'm wrong.
-Oh.
-Maybe you should host the show.
I'm a fool, I'm a fool.
-I'm just a dummy.
-Ladies and gentlemen,
I guess I'm a fool, I hope my
mother and father are watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm an idiot, I got you.
You're right, you're right.
-Oh, please.
-No, I appreciate you.
I appreciate you bringing me
down.
-Thanks for correcting me.
-My wife and kids
are in the audience,
but I appreciate you.
-Great.
-Appreciate taking me down
a couple notches.
Thanks a lot, man.
-Wow. [ Chuckles ]
Are you crying? Are you crying?
-No, I would never cry. It's
just someone's cutting onions.
-Oh, you're talking about a
flagel?
That's totally different.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Right, you ever have a flagel?
-I've had plenty of bialies.
[ Laughter ]
-Quest, flagel?
-Nah, no.
-Can we google a flagel,
is that real?
It's different than a bialy.
-Totally different.
-What is a bialy? Bialy --
Yeah, onions.
-No, not always. Bialy does not
always have onions.
-Whoa wait, whoa.
-Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
-Hey, you don't have to upset.
-My God, Bobby Flay called.
[ Laughter ]
-Flagel, bialy.
-Okay, okay.
-That's the last time we go.
-Alright.
-So he got upset or not.
-My wife and kids are in the
audience.
-Yeah.
-Thank you, thank you.
-Guys, is a flagel
the same thing as a bialy?
[ Audience, "No" ]
-Thank you very much.
-Cool.
-Tareek, I rest my case.
-Guys, does a flagel exist?
[ Audience "Yes" ]
Dope. Okay.
-Dope?
-Jury has spoken.
-That's, just --?
-Dome?
-Dope.
-Oh, dope.
-My work here is done.
-Thank you, guitar capos, for
being clothespins
that went to Julliard.
Deep cut.
-Boink.
[ Applause ]
-Thank you, coasters,
for letting me pretend
that my table is nicer
than it is.
[ Laughter ]
Don't really need it.
Just do it.
I paid for the coasters,
just use them, come on.
-It's a Formica table.
-So are the coasters.
-Oh.
-Thank you, flu shots,
for showing up
and knowing it's not
about you right now.
There you go, everybody, those
are our Thank You Notes!